Muslims about the riots issues good talk
about riots my advice you we have to yes
we have to defend ourselves defend our
mosques but however we should not when
we see the riot go to them or try to H
what they call it um instigate them
inate inate aggression them like you
know don't go to them don't approach
them you know because likewise
islamically why the some Muslims these
days but we have to make it clear don't
go to pubs attacking pubs don't go to
start attacking white people or
non-muslims the Islam has nothing to do
with it with this type of behavior yes
protect yourself defend yourself defend
the M if it's
needed but again remember the enem of
Islam they're looking for anything to
justify the hatred and gu Islam okay
Tommy Robinson Tommy Robinson is a liar
decea and his right hand the Dan Tomo he
came speaking 5 years ago he was here
last week he's lucky I didn't come I'll
expose him another time but anyway I've
exposed him and I show the people when
he speak about Jewish people and you
show them that the Jewish people believe
in stoning the adula killing the poor
State they will never say a word against
them why because Tomy Robinson is a
Zionist agent okay he works for the
Zionist they are his Masters that's why
I was very surprised with Andrew Tate
asking Tommy Robinson on Twitter if he
condemned
uh Israel you speaking to you speaking
to the dog brother you speaking to the
puppets understand so uh as I've
mentioned before Edo soy Robinson's
followers do not represent British
people they not represent Bri people
I've been country over 20 years okay
don't know those people are racist and
please stop saying they because they
have legitimized concerns about
immigrants and I want to mention
something the Muslim have a right to be
here why 4 million Muslims died for this
country in the World War
II 100 thousands of bangis and
pakistanis and Muslim Indians and
Africans died for this country CU Al
Andrew T speak about Bolis you know I
mentioned this before to show you the
the the the the which is the the
contradiction or the Paradox the Germans
those who try to destroy this country
The Offspring allowed to come this
country in out without of visa for six
months but the bangoli and the
pakistanis and the Indians and the
Africans the ancestors fight for this
country died for this country in the
World War II they're not allow to come
this country at all except with the VISA
okay R dictate they should they should
be allowed to come country without a
Visa honoring them to show them that you
respect what they ancestors did for this
country 4 mil 4 million Muslims died for
this country in the world War II like
was in France million of algerians
Muslims died for France in the World War
II helping the Muslims helping against
the tyranny of Hitler the Germans okay
so that's why you should learn the
history you know Subhan Allah and by the
way you having I need to die do you need
to die I need to die no you saying that
people die what do you mean
people Muslims died from his country the
world war yeah even if you don't die for
this country you still belong to this
country I agree with that you're right
100% but I'm saying if if if my if my
father dies for this country I have more
rights can I ask you a question when you
saying yeah and I'll disclose you may or
may not know yeah I went to South P when
on the within 24 hours of the fre young
ladies been killed and I live streamed
directly when the frames were when when
the police car and it was ried my is
what you all see yeah the question is
what was it like for you sir as a Muslim
yeah knowing that a Muslim had been
incorrectly blamed for killing the three
young ladies of course not feel good
it's not good feeling no doubt of course
I mean I was surprised when my daughter
said to me she's scared to go
outside cuz my daughter and I'm friend
to my daughter who she's she's 8 years
old 8 years old she's scared you
understand so and that's again show us
the danger of social media you know
social media don't spread anything
verify and this teach us of the how God
instruct us and and and and tell us how
to deal with information Allah
said if a sinner come to you with the
news verify it let alone unknown person
let alone someone who's a sinner racist
evil person spreading this light you
know and n faraj he blamed and youate
for misleading him that the guy was
illegal immigrant but to he said he was
a Muslim yes of course it's a it's no
good feeling to see people accusing
especially killing children which is
that we have a clearcut proves clearly
explicitly to say we all to kill
children Prophet Muhammad said that in
know in the in the war outside War but
we we know in the Bible you allowed to
kill children the Bible teaches that in
the Old Testament yes the old test he
said go kill the babies and infants
doesn't say that does he say that or not
does he say that or not does he say that
or not see that's why I want to talk
about him because I'm asking him we have
ever started he start playing around
imagine we start he can go to yeah you
can go tot you said ear does he say it
or not answer me does he say it or not
put him on the camera does he say kill
babies and infants kill babies and
infants in the Bible yeah what do you
have you read it and I'm ask does he say
it or not listen it talks about an event
it's not a
command it says it as part of an event
as event so he say it's not it's not a
command but is it coming for the Jewish
people because the Jewish people believe
they still have to follow the Old
Testament earlier on when we started you
men said earlier on you mentioned about
calling on your brothers to defend
themselves can I ask you to elaborate
specifically I mentioned what sorry to
you're calling your brothers to defend
themselves what do you mean by that
because I mean
they mean if if my example if the if the
far come into the MOs and try to harm
the Muslims then they have to defend
themselves physically yes but they're
not allowed to imagine the far outside
protesting don't go and fight them yeah
the best thing also to Cod authority to
deal with them you know because clearly
ad also on a mention which is very
interesting these people claiming
they're protesting because they want to
take their country back what they were
doing stealing from
shops stealing from doing what they call
it burning
Library please these people mentally not
well these are racist there's no
justification for what they're doing and
I agree with what his name stama the
Prime Minister clearly he said there are
evil no doubt brother Andrew T I
couldn't believe it Tred to justify what
they were doing you can't cannot justify
yes if they have concern yes in this
country allow it to protest peacefully
okay even though protest do nothing
anyway but anyway ACC course country you
allow it but attacking the Muslims for
something that have nothing to do with
it clearly you are racist evil liar but
is it possible that on the day so for
example when the riot started on the
Tuesday when I was there you know I
attended the visual outside of the Town
Hall
then I went to the location where the
girls were murdered and about 300 yards
around the road is when the riot start
but isn't it possible that the reason
people behaved or reacted the way they
did was because number one they were
provoked by the lies that were told by
the media and secondly they were
reacting in Anger that free young ladies
had been killed yeah I agree with you
because of the misinformation however
there are human beings there have their
own intellect they they will not like
for example in the
court one of them cannot say you know
because of the misinformation on social
media that's what I what I did that is
not valid reason that's not defense
that's not defense that's that's not
defense like for example when I see
videos of the Zionist killing my
brothers and sisters in Philistine
doesn't mean if I see a Jewish person je
a Jewish person I should go and fight
him and kill him no because it has
nothing to do with it you understand and
this is the beauty of Islam and this
exactly one our Scholars
mentioned said human nature when we get
angry we like to oppress okay and
transgress that's why you need a Divine
legislation to control your anger and
Islam comes for example we have from our
human nature we hate and we love Islam
comes in and it shows you the correct
way to hate and to love when you hate
someone you should not doesn't mean you
should lie against him or oppress him
when you love someone doesn't not mean
you should Aid him in his oppression and
transgression okay that's Islamic
teaching so sh all I can say thank you
very much for in the
war
it please you can
comp to thank you very much Shamy for
giving me this opportunity you always
engage with Street Mike I've had the
chance last week to question Ali dawa
I've questioned the shake all of the
heavy people wanted me to talk to you
because they see you as a heavyweight
down there but the only person you're
know one of the big boys but the only
person I mean the old school but the
only person ien with is mamed he's
hiding he's hiding know mamed is hiding
so if you're
in I want
to I mean maybe he will watch you and
you
can I know Ali sends it so I mean Al his
friend in closing you can say anything
you want the you got two I want to say
Sav to you personally like I said many
times to you think about yourself talk
about God let's have discussion about
God cuz I've seen you you focus too much
on people what about yourself that's why
you know the Quran that's why the Quran
teaches us look the beauty of the Quran
the teach of the Quran oh who you
believe save yourself and your family
from the fire you know every part of
your every part of your body has a
purpose what about you as a whole what
we here for what is our purpose what we
have to die what would happen to us
these questions cannot be answered by
scientists or doctors or philosophers
that's why you need to learn about Islam
you know why you you never told me you
believe to to answer your point it's a
good question you ask yes people often
ask me the same question if you look at
what I do I engage with everyone Muslims
Christians Jews a mean I do the same
thing not who they are you get you get
you get what I'm saying and I it's it's
what I'm trying to do is to educate
people out there in the bigger world
what you have to offer what they and
it's not because if I give my personal
point of view I can't engage with
everyone what you doing is like someone
feeding everyone forget himself that's
what you did order to help people order
sorry sorry in order to help people you
need to help yourself first okay because
say I mean young man tell you been
eating I'm but what we say you okay okay
listen carefully listen care definely
what we say to you what do you believe
my belief is irrelevant when I'm when
when I'm at Speaker's Corner again you
no the reason why no my my religion or
belief is irrelevant we want to have a
friendly discussion no no not not not on
social media we're not because because
cuz you believe in nonsense I you
believe I I have beliefs are you
Christian are you CHR I will engage I'm
answering your question I will engage
with people I do not agree with okay
let's engage there without without
camera because it's important I want Ali
darw is going to take me to a mosque and
I'm going to looking forward to spending
time in a m you don't work I'm I'm I
work for ny5 man I don't need to I got
my own you know you have your own Agy
I've been invited next week yeah to a
church to live stream yeah I'm willing
to you know wherever I don't care what
religion I don't come here toot iing are
you a Christian I don't come here to
promote religion no I'm asking at at
this moment in are you a Christian
journalist are you a Christian I am
nothing when I'm here see see I'm I'm
going to have interview like get blood
out of a stone not going to get out of I
need your help brother yes